[Music]  congratulations are in order for kate  middleton and prince william the royal  couple are expecting baby number three  kensington palace revealed the exciting  news in a royal press release on monday  stating the duke and duchess of  cambridge are very pleased to soon be  welcoming their third child together the  statement also read quote the queen and  members of both families are delighted  with the news  and revealed kate canceled an appearance  she had scheduled at the hornsey road  children's center due to illness  according to the announcement the 35  year old mother has been suffering from  acute morning sickness which she  experienced while pregnant with both  prince george and princess charlotte  prince george and princess charlotte's  uncle prince harry told the daily  express on monday afternoon he feels  quote fantastic about becoming an uncle  once again  [Music]